[Musik]
hallo meine lieben mit der zeit hat sich
ja so ein kleiner wie sage ich so ein
format entwickelt auf dem kanal und
angefangen hat das als wir eines tages
sonntag nicht zum kühlschrank hatten und
dann überlegt haben wir schon jetzt
einfach mal was wir uns damit machen
und das kam so peinlich verlinkt euch
das video mal in der infobox dass der
heute wieder sonntag ist wieder nichts
im kühlschrank haben und ich mir dachte
ich schaue einfach mal was ich euch
zauber ich hab mir überlegt ich mache
eine spielart lasagne und es sind sachen
die habe ich immer da ich zeige euch
hier gerne und zwar ist auf einmal
tiefkühl blattspinat dann habe ich ihm
natürlich immer zu hause milch mehl und
butter die gewürze sind curry hier habe
ich muskatnuss und salz später kommt
noch frischer pfeffer dazu und das habe
ich auch in meinem vorratsschrank
lasagne platten und für die spinat
lasagne gehe ich hier zuallererst mal an
den herd und zeigt euch wie ich die
masse mit spinat und creme mache
jetzt machen wir zuallererst mal eine
mehlschwitze für unsere soße dafür gebe
ich die butter in meine beschichtete
pfanne lass dich schmelzen
da die mittlere hitze und sobald
geschmolzen ist in einem schwung das
nehme dazu geben und dann gut rühren und
dann merkt er dass ja wie sage ich sage
das immer so ich erkläre dass wir mal so
dass dieses mehr so aussieht als würde
es atmen da kommen so kleine blasen wenn
das soweit ist das sehen wir gleich dann
kommt die milch nach und nach der schule
noch nicht gleich genau das meine ich
und jetzt ist es soweit jetzt den wir in
einem dünnen strahl in milch dazu
[Musik]
die milch ist jetzt komplett in der
pfanne und als nächstes gehen mit den
tiefen könnten spinat und die gewürze
und dann braucht der spinat so ungefähr
fünf bis zehn minuten bis sie schön
weich wird da könnte dann auch immer
wieder rühren
[Musik]
also sobald der spinat sich auflöst ist
ja eigentlich alles fertig wir warten ja
nur darauf dass der tiefgekühlte spieler
hat sich aufgelöst hat und jetzt fangen
wir an zu schichten dafür gebe ich jetzt
auf den boden der auflaufform schon mal
so ein bisschen von unserer spinat
kriegs damit er auch gleich nicht an
klebt und dann schichten mir ganz
einfach mit dem lasagne blättern und den
ofen habe ich auch schon vorgeheizt auf
200 grad ober und unterhitze und
anschließend beschädigt das einfach rein
ich denke das dauert 30 35 minuten und
dann gebe ich im nachgang ist endlich
auch schon mal sagen so ein bisschen
parmesan um drauf also später erst aber
ihr könnt natürlich auch im vorfeld
ungar dazu geben
[Musik]
und leckeres mittagessen steht auch
bereit mit nichts quasi mit nichts und
ja klar es ist kein festmahl aber ich
meine werden satt und es ist lecker und
das ist aller aller wichtigste das
riechen und es geht schnell und es ist
sonntag und wie haben trotzdem was du
isst dann mussten die vom lieferdienst
bestellt haben sie es eigentlich auch
total.com zwar nicht sehr einfallsreich
der hatte zwischendurch immer tolle
ideen ich bin dafür dass wir auch den
kartoffelkuchen machen hans als die idee
von kartoffelkuchen wollte den sehen sie
was kommt
also wenn dieser kartoffel kann sich gut
an
ich kann hier ein schreib mir auch hier
einen durch das format gefällt dieses
kurze und knackige sonntags format und
ja ok entschuldigen
ja ich hoffe ihr lassen sie das auch
sagen ein dampfte nach oben und
kostenloses abo und dann verabschiede
dich gibt natürlich immer instagram
folge und er macht den harzer folgen
schreibt so ok macht ihr lieben schießen
ich weiß noch ich
[Musik]